yeah watch this nature special on the
what are those animals that hang upside
down in Australia bats no they're like
furry they're furry and cute
Wallabies know every bounce around a
figure what they're called but one bats
no they got they've got him I got him
here too I think but anyway this
[ __ ] is on one side of the river
and he can hear a mating call from the
other side of the river and he's slow as
[ __ ] sloth sloth I thought
so this sloth here's the female sloth
and he [ __ ] me and I don't know where
they get these cameras from but they
watch this guy go down the tree across a
limb into the water can't swim for [ __ ]
there's [ __ ] Rapids he makes his way
well cuz he could hear that yeah gets
across climbs on it takes like two days
and then he finds this up his spot then
he climbs on top of her a couple shakes
of the head done Oh who's this [ __ ] but
now he can think I can thank you know
Jesus she wants to eat my fruit it's my
fruit [ __ ]
[Music]